foreign
is from Frederica
my name is Federico and I am from Malta
what do you do when you travel do you
stick to photos or videos
only like one of the mediums or do you
incorporate both
the reason I'm asking is because in the
previous years whenever I saw something
interesting now this could be locally or
abroad like for example a landscape I
used to
take a picture but also capture a video
now I'm looking back at all those
memories I guess you can call them and
I'm finding duplicates the thing is I
don't want to experience the same thing
in the future so I would like to know
what you guys think about it
I have two rules around photos when I'm
traveling two rules for photos when I
travel number one is I don't take
duplicate photos and so if I'm snapping
a photo of Ryan skateboarding down the
street and it's a little blurry because
Ryan's naturally blurry I'm just going
so fast on that skateboard I go fast
they call him the flash light
that's a triple entender there Nicodemus
don't even ask me how don't even try to
figure it out what's your second rule
Melbourne so the first thing is I will
take only one phone and let's say that
my thumb is in the picture or whatever
it's Charming it's screwy it's weird
here's the other thing that I do though
I take photos only of people
I don't take photos of places or things
you love people more than things dude
it's so hard to capture like in Sedona I
tried to take a couple pictures of the
scenery you just can't do it justice I
mean there are pictures of Sedona online
that do it justice but uh my iPhone does
not capture it the way you know a
professional photographer's camera
captures it right you know I I always
have the live turned on
on my phone so it's it's a video slash
picture it's only like a three second
video but um it's kind of funny because
I'll be going through those pictures
reminiscing and I'll hit the live button
and like it just usually captures
something silly because you know people
don't realize
no yeah but it's more it's you know it's
like Josh oh I got something in my teeth
like you just because it captures audio
as well so like you I always capture a
little snippet of something with the
live uh with the live photo but yeah I I
do like I I'm not uh as
um strict or rigid when it comes to
those rules but man I'll tell you
um you are right like capturing the
scenery you're very rarely going to be
able to capture I went to Malta which is
a very photogenic
um Island I literally Mariah and I were
like um planning a little trip and I was
like where's the warmest place in Europe
in September and Malta came up and I'm
like what the heck is Malta like I
didn't even heard of it yeah so I was
like well that's where we're going
because I've never heard of it and they
got some like really old ancient ruins
like some of the oldest ruins on the
planet and uh it was gorgeous it's just
it's an island just south of Italy like
you can actually see Italy on a clear
day from like certain parts of Malta to
kind of a tiny Island it's its own
sovereign country there's a little
island next to it called Gonzo that is
also Sovereign but part of Malta I don't
really understand that but
um long story short like it's so
photogenic and like you know I when I
was first there I'm like oh I gotta take
a picture of this and take a picture of
that and man
um not one of those have I put on
Instagram or or
framed or is Instagram worthy
um but yeah I I love I love that you
know taking pictures of people that
makes sense yeah I take pictures only of
people and I don't take duplicates those
two things help me travel so much more
lightly on my phone because I'm not also
pulling my phone out constantly to take
pictures of things it was funny Bex and
I went to Sedona like three or four
years ago and
afterward Ryan's like oh you got to show
me what it looked like and so I go okay
I pull up my phone and I go to Google he
sent me an image search
here you go friend but by the way those
photos were so much better and they
better communicated what it felt like
than if I were like here's a crappy
photo I took at the wrong time of day
and the lighting was off you'd be like
oh I don't really want to go there but
as soon as I showed you the best photos
it was like oh I could see myself there
someone else has already taken the
photos for me so I don't have to capture
everything I can let it go right now I
can experience it I can release it
without needing to acquire it because
that's what we're doing with our phone
later in this private episode we're
going to talk about the layer cake of
consumerism and one layer of that is
sort of experiential consumerism well
what is one way that we
experience consumerism which is also a
double entender here but we do
consumerism with experiences I need to
capture this I need to take the photo
capture the photo I need to bring this
home with me I can't let this go as
opposed to I can experience this and
when I'm done experiencing it it's
already gone you get to let it go yeah
all right so my two rules of of photo
taking is number one
um never take a photo if the act of
taking that photo takes you out of the
moment in a way that minimizes your
experience oh yeah you don't always have
to choose but sometimes you do and when
you do have to choose choose the present
moment to be fully available to the
magic of it the second thing is take as
many videos or pictures as you want but
everything that you take you gotta use
it even if you turn out not to like it
you gotta use it so one of my things is
I love taking screenshots of beautiful
quote that I see on my phone and so if I
take that screenshot I can't just let it
sit there on my phone taking up space
I'm now committed to using it by the
very Act of taking it so there may be
someone I think of who might also
appreciate this quote or maybe I'll
share it on social media or something
along those lines uh maybe there's
another site I know that uses those
types of quotes and I'll say hey here's
something that made me think of you you
might like if I take a picture of like a
beautiful church or I take a picture of
like something at the beach I gotta
share it and sometimes when I take those
photos I think oh I don't really think I
want to share this well go ahead and
keep the commitment and share it and
we'll incorporate that awareness into
the next time we take photos and that
balances the consumption with creativity
like you said Josh we have this tendency
to want to capture everything to consume
everything and there's nothing wrong
with capturing and consuming but it gets
out of balance when you're not creating
with what you capture when you're not
taking what you consume induce doing
something with it that sir curves or
enhances the life of someone else did
you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free
[Music]